commissioner stella kiriakides i'm very
pleased that you're convening this event
on women's cancers on this year's world
cancer day first let me say that women's
cancers are historically the forgotten
ones except of course for breast cancer
and thank goodness for that my own
oncologist tells me that one of the
reasons is that because breast cancer
also appears in more upscale
demographics women who suffer have had a
more powerful and often more public
platform to make breast cancer into a
public health issue with huge amounts of
research and private funding as well
that is the good news ovarian cancer on
the other hand is often called the
forgotten cancer and more ominously the
silent invisible killer of women this is
what i was diagnosed with last april but
i am pleased to report that i now have
my health totally restored thanks to my
incredible surgeon and my oncologist
both women both specializing in
gynecological cancers at europe's most
prestigious cancer center the royal
marsden hospital here in london i say
this because i am among the lucky ones
with private insurance and speedy
attention and also by listening to my
own body and insisting on investigating
my abdominal pain sadly and i would say
scandalously even shockingly it is still
true that too many women are often not
taken as seriously as men when they
present their cancer concerns to their
doctors or in the case of ovarian cancer
it's often immediately misdiagnosed as
for instance irritable bowel syndrome or
a urine tract infection or bloating etc
the worst danger is that ovarian cancer
is often recognized too late for there
to be a cure
leaving only management
my oncologist tells me that 80 percent
of ovarian cancers are caught at the
late stage and even worse during covid
now despite warning signs my own aunt
discovered her ovarian cancer at the age
of 79 and by then it was too late and
she died some six years later ever since
i've been extremely vigilant because i
had regular transvaginal ultrasounds and
i followed my plans to their conclusive
diagnosis i caught my ovarian cancer i
followed my pains which meant i caught
my ovarian cancer very early and that's
what made the difference between my life
and death so my message is that women
need to be taken seriously first and
foremost and that early diagnosis is the
key a major awareness campaign on
so-called women's cancers should also
take place for instance too many women
think that their cervical smear is an
ovarian scan it is not these are two
different body parts i'm someone who's
taken regular mammograms all the scans
and everything else that's on offer as
soon as i turn 50.
another effective cancer marker of
course is the blood test c125 that
detects unusual inflammation somewhere
in the body which should be an alarm for
further investigation again all these
options are not available to every woman
but they must be and if this event can
push women's gynecological health from
the back to the front burner of public
policy with proper research and funding
then that will be a conference worth
having
thanks for having me and good luck with
this important mission